lien box company asks Gary how long do
you spend creating a single piece of
content do you focus on video because
it's more natural for you lene this is a
great question and really ironic timing
so obviously you know for the from 2006
to deep into 2014 every piece of content
that came out came out for me then we
started building this amazing team and
so I assume you're asking about my
content I don't think about it at all
meaning I have religion of thank you
economy crush it and Jab Jab right hook
and I'm execute off of that clearly
comes from me weirdly insanely that
we're doing this question today because
last night I started using Twitter's new
video product where I can reply within
app and so I'm replying a lot more with
video and so when I was putting out
content to put out it was video first in
mind because I thought that was the best
way that I could communicate the reason
you're seeing so much more medium and
and garyvaynerchuk.com written articles
is Steve and India helping me transcribe
these things into written form so I
think that for me I did think video
first but it was hard to execute video
first for a while back in oh seven eight
nine
I had a flip cam with me and I would
tape stuff for that whole process now I
can do it right from the Twitter app
they made it available for verified
users so if any of you are verified you
can go check it out and I assume they'll
roll it out for everybody soon so I
don't overthink it I think way too many
people overthink it we're living in a
culture where kids are growing up
overthinking it every 14-year old girl
on the planet is taking an Instagram
photo that's taking her 47 minutes
because she needs the lighting just
right and then if it doesn't get enough
likes within the first four minutes
she's taking it down I have the reverse
of that rigger the the you know Mike and
I were working out last night talking
about like how much I've leaned down and
all these things and then I were talking
about people commenting and I was like
yeah of course because I would take
literally the most unflattering pictures
of all time I could care less about
lighting I don't even understand how I
think only this year I realized oh the
Lighting's got to come this way versus
me being in the light like right I mean
like I really really don't care about
the angles and things that make sure I
care about the substance I know I'm
pretty
keep the laps in
I want everybody know what the three of
you thought about oh you know keep the
stop keep the scoffs indie-rock next
question